hugo es un amante del peligro le gusta
ir a escalar dentro de volcanes activos
realmente le gusta el peligro de este
amigo acaba de escuchar un ruido
alarmante y decide salir del volcán lo
más rápido posible la elevación de hugo
relativa al borde del cráter del volcán
medida en metros y la vamos a notar por
eh
como función del tiempo en segundos que
está denotado por t se muestra en la
tabla a continuación hugo escala una
velocidad constante y bien nos preguntan
basándote en la tabla cuál de los
siguientes enunciados debe ser verdadero
de estos enunciados de acá y bueno si
nos fijamos en los enunciados todos nos
están hablando de cuál era la distancia
la elevación de hugo relativa al cráter
y cuál era su velocidad de escalada al
salir por lo tanto vamos a tratar de
usar esta tabla de aquí para averiguar
esos datos y bien lo primero que voy a
hacer es modificar un poco esta tabla
porque si se fijan no está en un modo
estándar generalmente tenemos la
variable independiente del lado
izquierdo y la variable dependiente del
lado derecho así que voy a tomar esto de
aquí esto de aquí
y lo voy a cortar
y lo voy a pegar por acá
muy bien más o menos algo así queda
bien entonces ya que tengo esto escrito
de este modo que al menos en mi mente es
más sencillo verlo así vamos a hacer un
pequeño dibujo para entender la
situación si digamos este es el cráter
de mi volcán el cráter de mi volcán
digamos esta es la falda del volcán aquí
por acá no sé por ahí está la lava
ardiendo y probablemente esté saliendo
humo y cosas así y vamos a decir que
este puntito aquí es precisamente hugo
que está tratando de salir del volcán
está dentro del volcán y quiere salir
y entonces esta tabla nos mide o nos
dice después de cuánto tiempo de que
empezó a escalar cuánto ha subido o
cuánto se ha elevado noten que como el
cráter está más arriba que hugo la
elevación de hugo siempre es negativa
respecto al cráter
eso significa nuestros signos menos de
acá pero bueno vamos a tratar de
entender lo que pasó quiero encontrar
primero el punto inicial de hugo la
elevación inicial de v cuando decide
salir y para eso noto que en el tiempo
te iguala 0 t igual a 0 la elevación de
hugo está en menos 24 metros por lo
tanto esta instancia original
que conversamos vamos a usar este esta
distancia original cuando uno decide
salir es de 24 metros y ahora vamos a
encontrar su velocidad para hacer eso
pues podemos utilizar la razón de cambio
cuando el tiempo aumenta en 4 segundos
cuando transcurren 4 segundos
delta acuérdense delta mayúscula
significa cambio en el cambio / es de 4
unidades positivas
es un 4 y a eso le corresponde un cambio
en la elevación de cuanto pues el cambio
en la elevación desde quizás debería ser
otro color
vamos a usar este verde
el cambio en la elevación de hugo es de
cuánto pues pasa de estar a menos 24
metros a menos 21 metros por lo tanto
tiene un cambio positivo de 3 metros en
su elevación de donde si yo quisiera
calcular la velocidad a la que está
escalando hugo tendría que decir cuántas
unidades de elevación cuántos metros ha
escalado dividido entre cuántos segundos
han pasado y eso me daría su velocidad
entonces cuánto es el cambio en la
elevación pues es 3 y el cambio en la y
el cambio en el tiempo perdón pues el
cambio en el tiempo es de 4 segundos por
lo tanto tengo que la velocidad de hugo
es de tres cuartos de metro sobre
segundo incluso podría ser una pequeña
gráfica eso también ayudaría vamos a
hacer una gráfica voy a poner este eje
de aquí que va a ser mi eje de elevación
y como la mayoría de las elevaciones
aquí en mi tabla son negativas también
voy a poner
en el tiempo de modo que tenga bastantes
números negativos a mi disposición este
es el eje el tiempo y el eje de la
elevación y bueno entonces yo sé que
cuando el tiempo está en cero cuando
estoy aquí cuando uno decide salir está
una elevación de menos 24 metros digamos
hasta por aquí menos 24 metros
y yo sé que cuando uno llega al borde
del cráter que es precisamente cuando se
elevación es cero
han transcurrido treinta y dos segundos
de que empezó a escalar así que aquí
igual a 32 de modo que la velocidad con
la que hubo escala o más bien esta es la
gráfica que denota la posición de hugo
respecto al borde del cráter
con relación al tiempo
y la pendiente de esta gráfica va a ser
precisamente la velocidad de hugo así se
interpreta la pendiente de esta gráfica
de aquí y esa velocidad es de tres
cuartos de metro sobre segundo de hecho
chequen por ejemplo si pasará de 4 a 12
entonces tengo un cambio en el tiempo un
cambio en el tiempo de 8 como es el
doble del cambio del tiempo esperaría
que el cambio en la elevación también
fuera el doble que este de 3 y de menos
21 a menos 15 también hay un cambio en
la elevación de 68 perdón 6 entre 8 de
nuevo son tres cuartos de metros sobre
segundo pero bueno chequemos las
respuestas hugo estaba 24 metros bajo el
cráter cuando decide salir y escala tres
metros cada cuatro segundos durante su
salida pues efectivamente está menos 24
metros
lo que acabamos de calcular que su
velocidad si nos dice que es cada tres
metros cada cuatro segundos por lo tanto
esta parece ser correcta hijo estaba 24
metros bajo el cráter cuando decide
salir y escala cuatro metros cada tres
segundos pues no acabamos de checar qué
escala tres metros cada cuatro segundos
no cuatro metros cada tres segundos por
lo tanto esto está mal
hugo estaba treinta y dos metros bajo el
cráter ahí ya puedo decir que estaba mal
esta opción porque hubo está a menos 24
metros o sea a 24 metros del cráter
hugo estaba a 32 metros bajo el cráter
cuando decide salir de nuevo hugo estaba
a 24 metros bajo el cráter así que la
opción correcta es esta primera de aquí